Đi ghi
Vì dân cạnh
Vì bình bị thích không xà rơ
Thống nào cho vào phòng nào
Phòng xúc không xúc bì luôn này luôn
Phòng nào bằng xí chi vụ cá
Hẳng hai người bà dự không qua hai người thằng tảm nè nghe khu trân hai mùa sấu
Chắc vào xình tình chà
Khiểm xa tả tình đề tên một bốn không, tổ tình chà khiểm xa xấu bốn
Chẳng kánh xa xấu tình xà
Phong kánh xa xa thông con anh tình bị bình phát hiện là người dân tị dân cạnh
Bình hình xa tả nè
Thì tình đào, tình chẳng xức tài dân để mình trở lại đi tài
Giờ người trở lại đi tài
Chẳng xấu tình chân để lại chú sát tổ chú
Hãy tình nặng nơi dân bị dân xa
Cánh bột, chân xí tổ con tắt lực thức xe dùng xe chân dụ
Cánh chân đều xí thêm đình chung tầm bị tê xa tổ chú ở đi cấp cư
Dù được hỗ trợ và đưa đình có xử dụi tế kì thầy
Sức bà của xí thêm đình này đã uống định
Hành động dân chăm, lấy chánh đường của cánh bột
Chẳng xí cánh xe dụi tình đào và phần dụng nơi dân tụi quang hình
Còn đỏ tụi tụi bian tài hình anh đẹp của người chánh xí cơ mà mình dân luôn gần dân
Sức xanh, xanh hỗ trợ nơi dân khi gập khó khăn hả nạc